possible evidence comes from an FBI raid
on an Arizona Warehouse in January 2014.
inside agents discover buckets of Limbs
and a female head sewn onto another body
destined for sale to the U.S military
the FBI files on this investigation have
been sealed so there's no real way to
know which bodies ended up at which
military bases and what kind of tests
they were subjected to
human experimentation at the base and
the image began decades ago
a lot of work is classified but some
programs like operation delirium where
U.S soldiers were dosed with PCP sarin
gas just to test the effects those types
of drills were conducted at this
location